[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will rank the most
powerful kaijus and giant monsters from
various movie franchises taking into
account their feeds and not power levels
since I don't know they're not from
Dragon Ball Z so let's get into it at
number 10 we have slatten from the
Pacific Rim Universe flattened the
category 5 kaju was one of the most
powerful enemies humanity and the
Jaegers have ever faced off against
Zlatan was able to easily overcome
strike Eureka a giant Mech robot with
just one hit from his technical Tales
Zlatan was also able to survive a
nuclear explosion in Point Blank Range
so with these Feats he definitely
deserves a spot on this list definitely
more powerful than most are the kaijus
from the antiverse number nine calm
coming on the ninth spot on this list is
the giant ape himself Kong has had many
incarnations ever since he first came
out in 1933 but the biggest and most
powerful version of his is from the most
of us where he straight up killed two
giant War bats nearly beat Godzilla and
in the end ripped out Mega Godzilla's
head clean off but this feat was only
possible due to attack team with the
G-Man himself nevertheless come is more
powerful than most most of us Titans and
kaijus from the antiverse
number eight Gamera the giant turtle
Kaiju isn't just protected by Blood
armor for his own franchise he also has
proven his worth defeating larger and
deadly opponents like the legion and
Iris compared to the G-Man who has the
highest strength and power Gamera
possesses better speed and intellect
however the main result of this conflict
would be that the two would not be able
to kill each other their strengths and
regenerative abilities are simply too
powerful and that is why he is on number
eight
number 7 the mega Kaiju this is the
combined form of three deadly kaijus
that the Jaeger makes from Pacific Rim
Uprising couldn't defeat and when
combined together into this deadly form
even a combined attack by several
Jaegers at the same time couldn't even
weaken him a bit the mega Kaiju is
easily the biggest monster from that
universe and could definitely defeat
most incarnations of gong and Gamera
with ease and against their more
powerful versions it would still have a
slight Edge in power and abilities
number six Mecca Godzilla the metallic
clone of the Big G is a Powerhouse and
depending upon its versions it could
easily fan off the previous entries the
most powerful incarnations are the most
diverse and the super Mecca Godzilla
from the heisei movies each version is
able to defeat their own Godzillas in a
one-on-one fight even though the most of
us Mecca was killed by Kong it was only
due to sheer luck and a combined effort
did it fall to The Big Ape and the giant
ax
number 5 destroya definitely the
deadliest opponent Godzilla has ever
encountered from the heisei movies
Destroyer could only be defeated by the
G-Man exploding at the cost of his own
life as well along with the shower King
Ghidorah and space Godzilla Destroy is
widely regarded as one of Godzilla's
most ruthless and terrible adversaries
unlike monsters who kill and destroy
accidentally or undermine control he
appears to be completely aware of the
Carnage and damage he creates and he
smiles
number four Glover the first Glover
master that appeared in the movie
Cloverfield was as tall as skyscrapers
and could withstand being bombed by the
deadliest non-nuclear weapons of the
United States but that's just a baby the
adult version seen in the end of
Cloverfield Paradox is leagues ahead in
size and power and yes the only way he
is on this list is due to his size being
miles a kilometers tall and therefore
being more powerful than others on this
list by sheer brute foes
number three the summer verminath going
up a notch in size this multi identical
base is even bigger and lives in the
vacuum of space seen in Solo a Star Wars
story The Sumo vermonaut lives in the
akiti's Maelstrom which is a chaotic
region of space surrounded by multiple
black holes yes this creature was so
powerful that it lives there ran free
and only died when it was sucked into
one of those black holes and even during
that event it nearly managed to escape
the pool of the Death Star
number two Ghidorah the arch rival of
Godzilla himself is on a second spot but
it's not the Astro monster from the
shower era or the heisei variations like
Mecca King Ghidorah or even Kaiser or
monster eggs and not even Master Zero
from the monster verse the entry here on
this list is the most powerful variation
void Ghidorah it is a reality phasing 20
kilometer long planet eater it was from
a different dimension and discarded its
physical body and only exists in Pure
Energy based form it devours worlds and
hence he is here on number two
and number one Godzilla from the many
variations and incarnations of the G-Man
none is deadlier than Godzilla Earth
from the anime movie here's a giant
plant-based monster who evolved to
become the most powerful life form on
the planet and defeated not just
Humanity but survived hundreds of
nuclear bombs drop all at once beat back
aliens with Advanced deck and decimated
void Ghidorah who is on the number two
spot he is the representative of the
Godzillas on this list and therefore
deserves the top spot
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam